the data shows us clearly that that if
you're a black child you're six times
more likely to be strip searched than
the rest of the cohort which I think is
worrying in itself but also
um we when we gave this evidence to our
evidence too on the Met police to Louise
Casey and she in her report talked about
the way black children are often seen as
older that could be one explanation I
have to say when I talk to parents of
black children what they say to me is
they're shocked but they're not
surprised now that's and I would say
this is happening all across the country
there's over representation nationally
it's not just in areas with large black
populations so I think this is really
serious and it's properly looking into
and frankly needs to change and change
now